You know, anyone doing whole body hypothermia with success?
Um, I don't.
We've had patients over the years
that have gone to Germany,
because that's really the only place
you could do a whole body hypothermia.
There's some German cancer clinics.
Now, quite honestly, I don't know how
and how successful they've been
and even keeping their doors open.
Years ago, the choice of getting alternative cancer
was to come to a clinic that was daring to step out
like we were 20 years ago,
doing what we were doing
and we were being bombarded by the medical profession.
There wasn't very many clinics in the United States
as you know, one is there are now doing anything
alternative in the United States.
So in order to do something like
if you looked at whole body hypothermia
the German cancer clinics were very popular into that.
The Mexico cancer clinics were not doing any whole body
hypothermia.
Um, really, I don't know if those German clinics
are even still open.
I know that German medical association has,
you know, since COVID has gone much more Western.
So I don't even know if those places still exist.
And that's where people received this therapy
in the past.
I understand whole body hypothermia
as you're going into this like,
God, and you're, you're being, you have an IV tube in you
and you're basically being completely sedated
in order to do this because you're trying to get your,
your core body temperature up to a fever state
of a hundred, I do a hundred and seven.
There's no way you would be able to tolerate that
without being sedated.
And that's for a long period of time anywhere between
four to eight hours.
It's just, it's a very intense and can be dangerous.
There's no clinics in the US.
There were, yeah, doing that to my knowledge,
no clinics still that are doing anything like that.
So I don't know of anybody who's done the whole body
hypothermia and doing it currently.